you know how we say in Samoa that when  the strong winds blow sometimes the  branches while they fall off the tree  and when that happens we just have to  get back on that horse and drive off and  and just rebuild that house I'm confused  is this about the tree or house where  did the horse come from what is this in  life things happen you may not want them  to but they do you just got to do your  best and move on the fact of the matter  is I'm your family  I'm your people me your whole whoa I am  a whole lot I just worry about you you  won't talk about your family any mom's  been gone for a long time I don't want  you to be alone look as long as I got  you kiddo I'm never gonna be alone you  and all your beautiful here never gonna  be alone I'm set for life  look at this perfect time  let me go cheat day you ain't cheating  the view I need oh no this is for Minnie  thank you so much thank you yeah thank  you so much thank you Jennie  [Music]